previously on oh that's right this is
just the exact same scene from last
episode that was cut off right before i
finished i mean it finished so
technically i've already given this
multiple sins but new day new sins also
immediately starting the show with
moaning and screaming so when myself and
everyone sitting around me at starbucks
find out my headphones didn't engage
because the jack is too full of pocket
lint my status is an upstanding member
of society is immediately called into
question and to those of you out there
sneering at the screen and calling me a
luddite for not having bluetooth
headphones the battery and those died so
i was using the backup set of wired
headphones with the accompanying dongle
it was the dongle damn it the dongle
failed me i'm a good person
take three steps up when i signal no one
on the other team hears them yelling
this plan out loud
slip-on shoes seem like a great idea
till you find yourself in a life or
death game a tug of war on a five-story
high platform breathing breathing
breathing excitement the commitment to
these three shapes has made it all the
way to the controls on these monitors
but why i get the commitment to the
whole theatricality of the game with
regard to the contestants but how does
this help anyone behind the scenes
what's your name huh
what do you care about that
so i can use your name duh number 240
would be the squid game champion at tv
sins even after the dorm when all no
holds barred in the last episode
establishing a severe lack of rules not
a single person takes the opportunity to
push a few of their fellow competitors
off the side of this osha violation
masquerading as a walkway did you see
that guy with his pants with a little
baby making fun of the people you just
murdered what exactly is the point of
the bows on the coffins i mean i get it
stack of the gift box they each receive
but there's no one to appreciate that
decorative decision this just seems like
wasted overhead the success of this body
harvesting scheme is somehow less
believable than the death game going on
upstairs never mind the absurd and ever
expanding number of people that have to
be involved in this plot and all the
infrastructure this process seems to
require the simple fact is it all hinges
on this masked individual recognizing
when this masked individual is looking
at the camera and knowing for sure that
they are the masked individual who is in
on the plan just think of the pileup
that would occur at the bottom of this
incinerator if another unwitting masked
individual just happened to be staring
in the general direction of the camera
for a moment he's not breathing go get
that doctor making me believe for even
one second that they're trying to help
this person from that movie what's it
called matrix hey when you got to korea
is all you did watch movies giving
someone a hard time for answering the
question you literally just asked oh
about that grandma why did you get
kicked out grandma
don't you ever call me that
more importantly why did he call her
that they look to be about the same age
it could be an issue with the dubbing so
i'll just give two sins just so we're
covered what can we do huh
we've got three girls an old man in us
it's like the writers didn't remember
this guy was there when his team won tug
of war against all odds we're all
sinners but we're still here aren't we
the opening dialogue of every tv sin
staff meeting somehow makes its way into
the episode you're not worried at all
those scumbags you got on your side over
there
are they people you trust this is all it
takes for gihan to get under this
asshole's skin a few words about trust
and he has him second guessing his
loyalties it's not like gihan is a jedi
wait is gion a jedi
joe thinks this slow ass double tap
would actually trigger an erase video
footage combo what's your reason for
being
in here the same as you
for money does this question even need
to be asked isn't everyone here because
they need money so in other words joe
has time for this number 29 so you're
finally here the only thing allowing
junhoe to get away with this is an
absurd desire to over techify everything
why go with this flawed mask scanning
when clearly a password secret handshake
or a polite yet awkward buttcheek grab
would have been more effective also the
scanning happens after they're already
in the room when this is definitely a
situation where you want to have your
accomplices identified beforehand
attempting to wake someone up by choking
them looks like you were having a
nightmare just now he was lying
perfectly still why is question saw game
i saw on the news doctors don't always
perform surgeries sometimes it's the
office managers or nurse's aides why the
[ __ ] is this scene also there's no way
doctors are letting office managers
perform surgeries right right
we don't have time for this being
self-aware doesn't absolve you of your
sin in fact it gets you an extra one
gihan is having flashbacks that we won't
be giving context for until later
directly after a scene where there's
exposition about the doctor helping some
of the squid game workers that we also
have no context for and based on what
happens to the doctor in this episode
i'm guessing we'll never have the
context needed all this is to say that
this episode is almost 100 filler which
will get you about
12 000 sinwon also this really feels
like the show is trying to retcon this
character mid-season let's not forget
this man is a terrible son and a
terrible father this sequence is making
me remember the mist and damn it i don't
like remembering the mist
no main character finds out older
character he looks up to a sick and or
dying cliche no it's fine i'm fine i
nearly pissed myself that night this
transition it's my fault the zombie was
missing a kidney this single kidney
individual gets the undercover agent
disguised as number 29 thinking he's on
the right path to find his brother
because his brother only had one kidney
as well however this isn't his brother
that they're talking about in fact it's
a female that well we'll see what
happens to her shortly anyways the
convenience involved to have two people
randomly selected for the squid with
only one kidney and then one of them is
talked about right in front of the one
person the story would affect the most
is driving me to drink are you happy now
squid game granted i'm only drinking
lemonade but do you know what all that
sugar can do to a person's body so what
happened
to that zombie what do you think
happened to it june ho damn near blows
his cover with this question as everyone
in the room goes on to explain that the
person he's pretending to be was there
for the incident the only reason he gets
away with it is that the doctor hangry
and needing a nap flips out and on that
i call
transporting organs in ziplocks pick up
the pace the boat's already here maybe
he's right but how exactly would he know
that they can't see the boat and no one
received a phone call or a text while
they were waiting for the dock to be
finished
his back survives this
don't touch it it's a bomb
they made this passage so the vips could
escape in an emergency since number 28
is assuming for the moment that this is
the real number 29 then why would he
feel the need to feed this exposition to
him the real number 29 would already
know all of this
now show me yours title of my sex tape
let's get you washed up before anything
else
show haunts me to believe that seven
people managed to silently enter this
room and the time it took for this guy
to turn around i'm gonna spare you from
having to listen to this man's
description of events all you need to
know is that it starts with necro and
ends with philia man i get the vibe the
show is going for but yuck
we have done that to a guy
that's where you draw the line now i
give the writers credit for adding
layers to even the minor characters but
when you lead with corp sex homophobia
comes across as a positive attribute
like we should be kind of happy he's not
willing to [ __ ] every corpse do you see
the corner you've painted us into go
check the list if you still don't trust
me i really want to move past this scene
but this just sounds like he's keeping a
list of dead bodies he's not willing to
necromance whether you sell the dead
body's organs or eat them or whatever
i don't give a damn or whatever like i
don't really want the show to elaborate
but i do but i don't but i kinda do
these people suffered from inequality
and discrimination out in the world
and we're giving them one last chance to
fight fair and win this insight that the
front man isn't just a faceless
administrator and might have motivations
beyond money and mindless killing really
adds depth to the story along with an
interesting social justice question
about fairness in modern society and i
think i like it now take a sin one off
before i change my mind
this episode has so many people being in
places where they don't belong and i'm
starting to believe that no one actually
works here it's kind of like that
episode of unbreakable kimmy schmidt
where we find out cats isn't a real
musical
this [ __ ] just discards this mask on
the ground like someone else is not
going to have to pick it up not going to
show it but it's the old bullet removal
with a knife cliche choosing black walls
for an interior room with no windows
instead of something more light and airy
you know to really open up the space
june ho is in what looks like a very
small document room by himself but
continues looking around with a
flashlight instead of just turning on
the lights if there are cameras in here
this will definitely draw more attention
to your activities and odds are if one
of the henchmen at their arcade game
workstation even noticed this they'd
probably just do the double tap video
erasure move because that's just what
you do when you see a member of the
redman group doing something they
shouldn't three ring binders also why
write the labels on the binders in
english when the rest of its contents
are in korean anyway the writers have
this shadow hide the picture of june
ho's brother because despite the fact
that most of the people in the show are
wearing masks it's necessary to keep
teasing us with the idea that we might
recognize who he is episode does not
contain a squid game
[Music]
don't tell me your kidney's gone get
yourself together and listen
i've got you i won't let go
hey you you got a visa i bet you don't
you're an illegal alien right right
somebody said alien she thought they
said illegal alien and signed up
mr brains you've been captain right
look at me i'm the captain now which
leads me to my second rule
the double tap
how do you expect me to operate with all
of that struggling damn it scotty it's a
rectal examination not an execution it
started glaring at me with one of its
eyes popping out
i saw it in my dream last night he was
surprised
i thought that body was my dead brother
it's okay but that spleen was a spitting
image
whether you sell the dead body's organs
or eat them or whatever
i don't give a damn don't you dare talk
about pineapple on my pizza
ever
you have failed me for the last time